republicans defend two seats to hold the
united states senate the coveted vaccine
rollout continues to hit speed bumps and
kamala harris plagiarizes from martin
luther king jr i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
this show is sponsored by don't like big
tech and the government's spying on you
well visit expressvpn.com ben to protect
yourself
well before we get started just want to
quick remind you quickly remind you
that you're spending too much on your
cell phone bill like way too much on
your cell phone bill you could be saving
over eight hundred dollars a year
simply by switching to pure talk usa
from verizon att or
t-mobile what would you do with 800
bucks well probably wouldn't send it to
your cell phone provider instead what
you would do is spend it on things that
you like
well here's the thing you can have the
exact same coverage as one of those big
providers with a lot less cost simply by
switching over to puretalk usa they've
got the same coverage the same bars as
one of the big carriers they charge you
half
you definitely don't have to sacrifice
customer service either their team is
based right here in the united states
they're some of the nicest people you
will ever talk to get unlimited talk
text and two gigs of data for just 20
bucks a month if you go over on data
usage they're not going to charge you
for it so here's the thing a lot of
these big providers they will say that
you need to pay all that money so you
have unlimited data but you're not going
to use unlimited data you're probably
only going to use
two gigs of data and then with pure talk
even if you go over they're not charging
you extra so what exactly do you have to
lose grab your mobile phone dial pound
250 say ben
shapiro when you do you'll say fifty
percent off your first month dial pound
two five zero say keyword ben
shapiro pure talk is simply smarter
wireless against i'll pound two five
zero say keyword ben shapiro and when
you do
you save 50 off your first month of pure
talk
usa coverage okay so let's jump in today
with a story that should make you happy
it should make you happy because
it just demonstrates once and for all
that if you are looking for principal
in the same place where you find
politicians you are looking in
in the wrong place indie they're digging
in the wrong place so kamala harris and
she's being touted as the next
great thing she's so great kamalaris
kamal harris was so great
that she ran in the democratic primaries
and dropped out before her home state of
california had even voted
that was after being the early
front-runner for the nomination based on
calling the guy she would eventually be
the running mate to
a racist and don't you remember all this
i know it's been like a year and this
this this year has been 20 years but
when that race started kamal harris was
considered a frontrunner because she
fulfilled two things that the democrats
desperately wanted she was a woman
and she was black sure she was
unqualified sure she wasn't very good on
stage
sure she was incredibly rehearsed and
had this weird cackle that she would
break into for no reason at all somebody
would say something weird or
uncomfortable or she would simply
ask a tough question and she would just
break into this joker-like cackle
this insane this insane bizarre laughter
that nobody could really understand
she was so off-putting that after she
called joe biden a racist on the stage
she couldn't back it up right then she
suggested joe biden might have to drop
out of the race because of sexual
harassment concerns
and then she was like you know what i'm
going to forget all that and i'm just
gonna become that guy's vp so
kamal harris is not the most principled
of people i mean i think it is fair to
say that kamala harris and principal
have probably never met in fact they
probably have not been within a 300 mile
radius of one another kamala harris
and principal but because she's a
democrat and because she's a
self-identified woman
this means she gets cover stories in
places like l magazine because this is
the way
our disgusting media works here's the
thing more people probably engage
with this sort of checkout counter
supermarket tabloid
magazines the in-touch magazines and the
in-style magazines and the l magazines
than they do overall with you know kind
of normal political publications
and so it actually makes a difference
when these sorts of publications feature
on their covers people
like kamal harris but of course i never
remember them doing anything like that
with sarah palin in 2008 when she was
running for vice president with john
mccain she didn't get that same sort of
coverage okay so
kamala harris is now being recast so as
soon as joe biden picked her
she went from being this loser who was
incapable of getting her campaign
together was extremely off-putting
very awkward nobody really liked her she
went from that too what a godsend kamala
harris is i mean just
unbelievable the intellect the brains
the charm the beauty all in one
incredible package
literally four months before the media
were like yeah they wrote her off for
dead they were like okay yeah she was
really bad at this
then biden picked her and suddenly she
had been elevated to godly positions
like moses anointing joshua his
successor was incredible
this incredible scene the light shined
down from heaven and kamala harris
became awesome
again she became incredible again she
was a heroine
for the ages and then she did precisely
zero
serious hard-hitting press conferences
between the time she was nominated vp
and the time the election took place
well now we can sort of see why this was
i mean you knew before right she's bad
at this
but now you can totally see why this was
because this is my favorite story of the
day it's so good so l magazine
features kamala harris in their culture
section and this is what your
friends in the media do and they are not
interested in putting kamala harris in
their politics section she's in their
culture
section you see because culture is
always upstream of politics and
they have this long puff piece about
kamal harris here's how this puff piece
starts
because it's wonderful here's how this
pup starts you ready here we go
senator kamal harris started her life's
work young
she laughs from her gut the way you
would with family
okay have you ever heard kamala harris
laugh um
she laughs from her gut the way you
would with family if you were then going
to you know
bomb gotham city as she remembers being
wheeled through an oakland california
civil rights march in a stroller with no
straps with her parents and her uncle
at some point she fell from the stroller
few safety regulations existed for
children's equipment back then
and the adults caught up in the rapture
of protest just kept on marching
by the time they noticed little kamala
was gone and doubled back she was
understandably upset
my mother tells the story about how i'm
fussing harrah says and she's like baby
what do you want
what do you need and i just looked at
her and i said freedom
this is what kamelahara says okay so
first of all to start a story that way
is the dumbest thing i have ever heard
in my entire life
okay if your story your political story
begins when you're a toddler who fell
out of a stroller
even if that story happened to be true
which it's not as we'll get to in just
for a moment
that is a weird weird take when this is
like one of those twitter takes where
people like
my seven-year-old daughter came in the
room and she asked me mommy
why is the gender wage gap so wide when
we've taken so many steps to alleviate
the gender wage gap through federal
legislation
and i looked at her and i cried it's one
of those twitter stories
hey where i fell out of the stroller and
then my mommy looked at me and said what
do you mean i said
freedom by the way in the story it is
spelled f-w-e-e-d-o-m
freedom now there is a one problem
with this story aside from the fact that
it is really really ridiculous
it also happens to be lifted directly
from martin luther king jr
so it turns out that plagiarism
apparently runs throughout like if you
get within
a certain distance from joe biden the
plagiarism is contagious it's like covet
except plagiarism
you start sort of plagiarizing things
and this is elizabeth warren type stuff
she's just taking other people's
personal stories and making them her own
right but that's that's okay right it's
her truth here is a
an interview from a 1965 playboy with
martin luther king by alex haley right
the guy who's
who wrote roots hey you ready for this
here it is
i will never forget a moment in
birmingham when a white policeman
accosted a little negro girl seven or
eight years old who's walking in a
demonstration with her mother
what do you want the policeman to ask
her roughly and the little girl looked
him straight in the eye and answered
feed him she couldn't even pronounce it
but she knew
it was beautiful so kamala harris
maybe it's the same girl maybe it was
kamala harris that little girl was me
says kamala harris maybe it's kamala
harris or maybe politicians are the
worst sort of skunks
and they lie to you continually and they
are ridiculous and when the media act
credulous with regard to democrats
but absolutely critical with regard to
republicans they undercut themselves
when the media prints interviews like
the one that l did with common
by the way i'm sure kamala harris has
told that story a million times i'm sure
that she trotted it out over and
people today were saying well did she
think she was going to get away with it
well yeah
why wouldn't she seriously why wouldn't
she it took until now for anybody to
fact check her story
if you're a democrat the most beautiful
thing about being a democrat is that
elizabeth warren can lie for three
decades about being native american
and it's only when republicans are like
oh yeah by the way she's not native
american
that that becomes a real story for her
remember republicans brought that up in
her original senate race in
massachusetts
and the media were like you can't say
that about elizabeth warren she has high
cheekbones
so if you're a democrat of course the
incentive is for you to make up the most
dramatic possible stories
in which you're a four-year-old and
you're telling cops that you need
freedom
absolutely insane and ridiculous but i
think it puts us in minds of where we
stand
in politics and again don't seek higher
values in your politicians you're not
going to find them there by the way
check out matt walsh's show today
he's going to have his take on that
story he'll also be discussing white
musicians who decline grammy nominations
because they're white and also busy
phillips
is this actress i guess and she posted
about her non-binary 12 year old child
weird how many members of the hollywood
community who are very very warm toward
a particular ideology have children who
then fit particularly squarely within
this ideology strange strange
okay so that is your kamala harris
starter for the morning that's just the
appetizer gang
pretty solid stuff okay the big story of
the day obviously is this runoff
in georgia there are two separate
republican seats that are up
in georgia right now the senate is split
50 to 48
in favor of republicans if democrats
would win both of those seats it would
be split 50 50 and kamala harris
a little girl who knew freedom would be
then the person who decides all the
votes
in the senate so that means that these
races are extraordinarily important
extraordinarily
important and it means that regardless
of what you happen to think about what
happened in georgia
whether you're on the trump bandwagon
suggesting that georgia
the votes were falsified and he actually
won georgia or he didn't win georgia
all of that is purely irrelevant
irrelevant to the question of whether
you want democrats to run the united
states senate
if you are following lynn wood down the
primrose path to hell here
and you're saying i'm going to sit home
because i am mad about the election
understand the lincoln project
those bunch of grifters the lincoln
project have been pumping out
lynn wood and his bizarre conspiracy
theories to try to encourage republicans
to stay home these are the same people
who say that stacey abrams is a hero for
fighting voter suppression trying to
suppress the vote by quoting lynn wood
to the effect that georgia is already
rigged in favor of the democrats
do not stay home you need to go out and
you need to vote
right now it is if not a toss-up very
close to a toss-off
this toss-up so the polling data again
is is somewhat sporadic and people are
very
queasy about the polling data as well
they should be after all the polling
misses in the last election cycle
remember they're a bevy of polling
misses particularly down ballot
right they're a bunch of senate races
that went to republicans despite the
fact that the polls had suggested they
were gonna go to democrats there are a
bunch of
congressional races that did the same so
right now
if you look at the if you look at the
the polling data it would suggest that
john ossoff has a very slight lead on
sunny perdue
according to 538 assaf is up 49-47 over
purdue which is weird considering that
purdue beat
ossoff just a couple of months back he
just didn't reach the 50
threshold necessary to retain the seat
outright
uh purdue beat him by like 80 000 votes
so that's a big margin for assaf to have
to make up
meanwhile the other polling data shows
warnock with a with a
two-point lead 2.2 point lead over kelly
lefler
right now the markets seem to be hedging
on this the markets are very uncertain
where all of this
is going especially considering the fact
that if the democrats were to take the
senate they would immediately
shift into high tax gear they would move
into high tax mode high regulation mode
the market is starting to sell off
as of this morning looking at the
possibility of a democratic senate nate
silver says
that the democrats have to be favored in
probably both races by slightly
like a little bit at this point which
means that if you're a republican you
cannot afford to stay home
do not stay home the data tends to show
that the early voting
tends toward the democrats it trends
toward democrats and then day of trans
republicans there's been a lot a lot of
early voting now there's a theory out
there put forward by eric erickson
who's a radio host down in georgia
and eric suggests that a lot of the
early voting is actually republican
because republicans have learned
that not early voting is a really bad
idea so a lot of republicans are early
voting as well if that happened
then that would be a hidden vote for
republicans that has not yet been
identified because again all the
modeling is based on the old models
where democrats voted early and
republicans
voted day of according to the new york
times three million people have already
voted in the runoff races
nearly 40 percent of all registered
voters in the state that total surpasses
the 2.1 million ballots cast in the
state's last senate runoff election that
happened in 2008.
the early voting data suggests the races
are very competitive some indications
democrats had a bigger share
of the early voting electorate than they
did in the general election raising
hopes for a party that has traditionally
been the underdog
in runoff races the general supposition
was that republicans were going to have
the advantage here because
trump had driven out democratic turnout
he had like a lot of democrats showed up
just to vote against trump in places
like georgia and with trump not on the
ballot a lot of democrats would simply
not vote this time around while
republicans would be focused laser-like
on preventing the democrats from taking
the senate that has not happened
one of the reasons that has not happened
is probably because president trump
continues to make georgia
the livest issue but he's not focused on
pennsylvania anymore he's not focused on
arizona
which is weird because obviously even if
trump wanted to retain the presidency he
would have had to show that he actually
won arizona georgia and pennsylvania
shifting the vote in georgia doesn't
change a damn thing he would actually
have to win all three of those
in order for him to retain the
presidency and it's a moot point anyway
because all of these states have already
certified their votes
but what that has done is it has made
trump front and center
in the georgia senate races and it has
also driven down
republican enthusiasm for the race
because many of those people are angry
at the republican party of georgia for
apparently not shifting
their perception of the votes or
certifying the votes or whatever
so what exactly should we expect well in
november
sunny david perdue received 49.7 percent
of the vote just short of the majority
he beat
us off by 88 000 votes on the other side
warnock had 32.9 percent of the vote
kelly lefler had 25.9 percent of the
vote but the difference is that uh
warnock and leffler also had doug
collins
in the race it's unclear exactly
when we are going to know the result
some of the rules were tweaked to
encourage a faster count
the new congress was already sworn in on
sunday according to the new york times
counties were required to begin scanning
and processing ballots at least a week
before the election but they can't begin
counting or tabulating them until the
polls close on tuesday
the new rules might lead to quicker
results although in a close race most
georgians may go to sleep before the
news outlets have enough results to
declare a winner so we could
be well into tomorrow before we actually
know who
won these particular senate seats and it
is very very important who wins these
senate seats so eric erickson again i
mention him because
he is sort of closest to the action
there he believes that david perdue
is uh is in good shape against jon
ossoff
he says that ossoff has been tying
himself to raphael warnock
because warnock is outperforming
particularly with black voters ossoff
does not have the same appeal with black
voters that warnock apparently does
and so assaf has been tying himself to
warnock's leg and attempting to push
warnock over the finish line and in
return
hoping that warnock helps black voters
vote for him
according to erickson he says quote
assaf can't save himself maybe he can
help warnock
that ossoff is having to play attack dog
and his tag team with warnock also
reinforces the idea that warnock's
unfavorable rating has skyrocketed
it really does appear that purdue has
enough black and hispanic voters voting
for him over farming and agricultural
issues that ossoff probably cannot pull
it off the real race and focus is now
on warnock and lefler the races are both
tight if you follow the money and the
attacks around the state and notice what
the black farming community in south
georgia is doing the republicans
probably keep the senate so
that makes me feel at least a little bit
better in just a second we're going to
go through all the reasons
why actually of the two democrats the
one who certainly
should not be in the senate is rafael
warnock rafael warnock is a radical
marxist raphael warnock is a disaster
area of a human being
there is no way that the schmuck should
be in the senate of the united states
and i say that advisedly because the
senate is filled with schmucks
this guy would be one of the one of the
more egregious schmucks in the senate of
the united states
i don't want to hear any more about
radicalism inside the republican party
when you guys are all rooting on the
democratic party for raphael warnock a
man who has endorsed louis farrakhan
jeremiah right in fidel castro spare me
spare me the crocodile tears for just a
moment if you're going to continue along
those lines
we'll get some more of this in just one
second first if getting life insurance
is on your to-do list for 2021 policy
genius can help you cross it off with
ease and it should be on your to-do list
because if you are a responsible human
being you want to make sure that your
family is taken care of in case god
forbid something should happen to you
well policy genius makes the magic
happen for you they make it easy for you
to compare more than 30 top insurers at
once and save over 50
in the process there's no hassle because
their licensed experts work for you
not for the insurance companies here's
how it works first you head on over to
policygenius.com
in minutes you can work out how much
coverage you need and compare quotes
from top insurers to find your best
price
policy genius will then compare policies
starting at as little as one dollar a
day
you might even be eligible to skip that
in-person medical exam
once you apply the policy genius team
will handle all the paperwork and the
red tape if you hit any speed bumps
during the application process
they'll take care of everything for you
soup to nuts make this the year you
finally cross
life insurance off the to-do list get
protection for your loved ones it is
super important stuff go to
policygenius.com
right now get started you could say 50
or more by comparing quotes start the
new year with one
less thing to worry about there are a
lot of things in life to procrastinate
about life insurance is not one of them
because if you procrastinate and you are
wrong it is then too late officially it
is
wait for you to get life insurance once
you have failed policy genius when it
comes to insurance it is nice very
important to get it right say 50
or more by comparing quotes over a
policy genius today
okay so raphael warnock is a disaster
and i think it's worth playing some of
raphael warnock's greatest hits here
because as a reminder i don't care what
you feel about the presidential election
i don't care what you feel about
president trump
or about the senate challenge i don't
care what you feel about the electoral
college when it comes to the
senate race these and by the way you
know who else doesn't care trump right
trump was down there last night in
georgia
rallying for left flutter and purdue
saying it's important for the
republicans to retain
the senate it is particularly important
to keep rafael warnock out of the senate
raphael warnock john ossoff is just like
a normal democratic socialist
he's just he's your normal everyday
trust fund democrat socialist
who has bad views and is extraordinarily
disingenuous raphael warnock is a deeply
radical figure
an extraordinarily radical figure and
basically
john ossoff is is just sort of a a pete
booty judge type
he's somebody who who mimics barack
obama's patterns of speech
and who is fluent in lies and says
socialistic things
but that's about it rafael warnock truly
down to his bones believes
horrible things about the united states
so just a few of raphael warnock's
greatest hits for the media that didn't
cover them because the media have
decided that rafael warnock is actually
a godsend the new york times printed a
piece
over the weekend talking about how
rafael warnock loves to speak
uncomfortable truths but what if he
likes to speak
uncomfortable lies what if he says
horrible things on a regular basis so
for example
what would you think of a candidate who
praised louis farrakhan's nation of
islam as important well
here is rafael warnock doing just that a
couple of years a couple of years ago
the nation of islam is significant
but its numbers don't come anywhere near
the membership of our churches
it's its voice has been important and
its voice has been important even for
the development of black theology
because it was the black muslims who who
challenged black preachers
that is the person who they want to
elevate to the united states senate what
if you have this guy saying on tape
that fidel castro's cuba is very much
like the united states of america oh
wait we do
we pray for the people of cuba in this
moment
we remember fidel castro whose legacy
is complex don't let anybody tell you a
simple story life
usually isn't very simple
his legacy is complex
kind of like america's legacy is complex
it's true
fidel castro's legacy is complex like
you know jailing tens of thousands of
dissidents
creating a living situation so bad that
people literally attempt to
float cars from the 1950s from cuba to
the coast of florida
but it's a complex legacy says raphael
warnock that guy
is the person that the democrats
desperately want in the senate okay
what if for example this person had
suggested that america worships
whiteness
this person running for the united
states senate in a majority white state
because georgia is a majority-wide state
like every other state in america so far
as i'm aware except for i think
california which is now plurality
minority
raphael warnock saying that the state in
which he lives
right worships white like white people
are worshipped in the united states as
rafael warnock
interesting take from person the
democrats desperately want in the senate
and if it is true that
a man who has dominated the news and
poisoned the discussion for months needs
to repent
then it is doubly true that a nation
that can produce such a man and make his
vitriol go viral
needs to repent no matter what happens
next month more than a third of the
nation that would go along with this
is reason to be afraid america needs to
repent
for its worship of whiteness what a
sweet fellow
i mean why shouldn't that guy sit in the
united states senate what if we had you
know this guy on tape
suggesting for example that you can't
both be in the military and serve god
well what if you had that guy on tape in
a state like georgia which is a heavy
military state
should that guy be in the united states
senate democrats say you need him in the
senate rafael warnock again this is like
the easiest
the apple research on warnock is the
easiest thing in the world you just look
at what he said
and yet democrats are down there
campaigning for him the media are
covering for him
in real time the media honestly like
figuratively the the media establishment
needs to be burned to the ground
figuratively for those of media matters
the media establishment
is awful awful awful awful if the
republicans had said anything remotely
equivalent to this on the other side
it would be the headline for days on end
every democrat would be asked if they
agree with this every single one
i'm old enough to remember when a
congressional candidate named todd aiken
said something weird about rape and
abortion
something bizarre and strange about rape
and abortion missouri race
several election cycles ago every single
republican in america was asked about it
raphael warnock says things like
fidel castro is a complex person a
nation of islam is great
he also by the way says that israel is
routinely committing human rights
violations
and is and is horrible and evil and the
palestinians are are just
the the sad victims of all of this he
says that america
is uh is a racist place and he says that
nobody can serve god in the military
and not a single democrat has been asked
about rafael warnock's comments not one
that is the easiest litmus test in the
world for how biased and disgusting our
media are so here is rafael warnock
saying that you can't serve both god and
the military which is a hot take if ever
i've heard one
america nobody can serve god and the
military
you can't serve god and money you cannot
serve
god and norman at the same time
america choose ye this day whom you will
serve and everybody's cheering oh how
wonderful what
a wonderful guy what a wonderful
wonderful guy we'll get some more of the
greatest hits of rafael warnock in just
one second
a lot of stuff that you're not going to
hear unless you actually pay attention
to alternative media because the regular
media are just the mouthpiece for the
democratic party that's all they are
they they're just a media matters
democratic party mashup that's all they
do now
it's pretty incredible we'll get to more
of it in a second first let's talk about
one area of your life where you might be
vulnerable to people stealing your
assets that you might not have thought
about so
you think about many things that you own
that are worth a lot of money
the thing you own undoubtedly that is
worth the most money is your house and
nobody can steal your house right i mean
nobody's gonna like back up a truck and
then just drag your house away
but what they can do is they can access
your home title i got a crash course
into home title theft and uh it is not
good here's how the crime happens
the legal titles to our homes are kept
online they can be hacked
a cyber thief finds your home's title
forges your signature on a quit claim
deed
stating you sold your home to him then
he takes out loans against your home
until all the equity is gone you're not
going to know until the collection calls
pour in
you're not protected by insurance or
your bank or common identity theft
programs
home title lock protects you in the
unlikely event you become a victim of
title theft while a member
home title lock will spend up to a
quarter million bucks in legal fees to
help restore
your home title it's your most prized
asset you shouldn't let people access
the value inherent in it go to
hometitlelock.com register your address
to see if you are already a victim then
use code radio for 30 free days of
protection that is code radio
at home title lock dot com again that's
home title lock.com okay a few more
greatest hits from raphael warnock since
apparently the media don't care about
any of these
well what if uh rafael warnock were on
tape saying that racism is america's
pre-existing condition oh wait he is
we've got a lot of problems but i would
not
be a prophet if i did not tell you that
racism
is america's pre-existing condition in
this land where we warehouse
25 percent of the world's prisoners
although we are only five percent of the
world
we ought to ask ourselves what has it
cost us not to
cover it not to face up to it not
to confront it not to deal with it
racism is america's pre-existing
condition okay this guy is considered
the stronger candidate in georgia
between ossoff and warnock this guy is
considered the front-runner
among the democrats in georgia like he's
the stronger horse in georgia
why because the entire democratic
liberal establishment has bought into
the
ridiculous critical race theory
suggestion that america is inherently
racist its institutions are inherently
racist
and then only the people who speak truth
to power like raphael warnock have
legitimacy
to say this kind of bull crap routinely
i mean the
man's on tape preaching marxism and
preaching that america is a racist
nation
and then what does he do he goes into
the mainstream allies and he says my
story could only happen in america
the sort of two-facedness when it comes
to politics is
again common but gross here is that
raphael warnock openly preaching marxism
again
all this is on tape where are the media
for all this they don't care they don't
care
this guy ought to be in the senate of
course i love this pope he said well i'm
not a marxist but i know a few marxists
and they're pretty good people
so hard to discover and to hear an
authentic vision and voice of authentic
spirituality that gives voice to the
least of these that when it
shows up people describe it as some
strange
ideology rather than the vision of that
poor palestinian prophet who said
that the spirit of the lord is upon me
okay there's so many things wrong with
that
number one jesus was not a socialist
number two jesus was not a palestinian
because palestinians did not exist
the palestine did not exist it was judea
idiot
he's a he's an anti-semite he's a racist
and he also happens to be
like a pretty wild character in his own
right
okay i mean by the way when you're
talking about your fealty to biblical
text
and fealty to the bible you might not
want to say that abortion is consistent
with your christian views that's it but
but that is what he says i mean
that's what all good christians say so
far as i'm aware is that killing the
unborn in your womb is totally something
jesus was up for
i believe that health care is a human
right
and i believe that it is something that
the richest nation in the world provides
for its citizens
and for me reproductive justice is
consistent with my commitment to that
uh i believe unequivocally and a woman's
right to choose
and that the decision uh is something
that we
we don't want government engaged in i've
been focused on women's health oneness
choice and reductive justice
uh that is consistent with my view of
uh as a christian minister oh well you
know if it's consistent with his view i
mean
not consistent with the bible but if
it's consistent with his view then of
course we should take it very seriously
as far as him on a personal level and
now turns out according to jim garrity
over at national review
that rafael warnock has had some trouble
paying his taxes and fees in fulton
county georgia
four times in six years warnock as ceo
of ebenezer baptist church
had tax liens imposed against him for
failing to pay for trash collection and
recycling the fulton county tax
commissioner collects fees for trash
collection
and recycling on behalf of the city of
atlanta
for those wondering if the church would
be considered exempt uh no
the church is not considered exempt so
he he makes about 250 000
a year by the way leading that
congregation but he couldn't pay the
trash fees
he's a delight also caught on tape an
altercation between him and his wife and
the police in which his ex-wife uh
accused him of running over
her foot with a car and then talked
about how innately dishonest he was this
got zero
broad coverage in the mainstream media
right fox covered it
we covered a little bit here it wasn't
covered at all by the new york times or
cnn so far as i'm aware or if it was it
was in very very minimal
fashion imagine if a republican's
ex-wife had come out and made
allegations
about this sort of thing well probably
that would put barack obama in the
senate in 2000 in 2006
probably something like that with jack
ryan and jerry ryan in any case here is
rafael warnock and his ex-wife caught on
tape
all right so you walked over so i'm like
moving and she won't move and she's
keeping the door open
so i'm like chloe just stay in the car
and i move and i close
my car door get in the car and i
start to move slightly thinking she's
here clear yeah i'm thinking she's clear
and i barely move and all of a sudden
she's screaming
that i ran over her foot i don't believe
it i've tried to keep the way that he
acts
under wraps for a long time and today he
crossed the line
so that is what is going on here and
he's a great actor
he is phenomenal at putting on a really
good show
believe all women unless they happen to
be making allegations about rafael
warnock in which case don't believe the
woman ignore the story
and pretend that rafael warnock is a
good guy other indicators that perhaps
raphael warnock is not such a wonderful
person
uh not only did he praise fidel castro
in 1995
right he he was a youth pastor of a
church that hosted castro and people
chanted
fidel fidel's name in that congregation
not only that he has also praised
jeremiah wright
and he suggested he says jeremiah wright
is a truth-teller
right jeremiah right that you know the
g.d america guy the guy who said that
the chickens came home to roost on 9 11.
well raphael warnock says you ought to
go back and see if you can find and read
as i have the entire sermon it was a
very fine sermon
jeremiah wright was right when he said
the attack on him was in a real sense an
attack on the black church
the message of jeremiah wright was that
public policy has consequences
he also called writes sermon a quote
very fine homily in his 2013
book and he compared jeremiah wright to
jeremiah
okay this person is who the the
democrats believe must be
in the united states senate by the way
also the same guy who uh was charged at
one point
for obstructing an investigation into
child abuse the charges were later
dropped
is it a summer camp there were
allegations of child abuse apparently he
tried to get between the police
and people they were questioning he's a
delight
but democrats are down there saying
rafael warnock ought to be the front
runner for the
but again he is the one who is most of
the two democrats he's the one who's
more likely to end up in the united
states senate which says something
about this disgraceful state of our
politics and that guy shouldn't be
within
sniffing distance of the united states
senate meanwhile
in the other race you have john ossoff
running against david perdue
and ossoff is not running against david
perdue assaf is running against kelly
lefler
right he is trying to boost warnock and
he's trying to attack leffler because
his goal here is to be the attacked off
on behalf of warnock
hoping that warnock's black support will
then translate over into support for
john ossoff so he's going out there and
he's just saying overtly false things
about kelly lefler
so over the weekend he was asked
specifically about the fact that he is
covered up for example his own
involvement with chinese firms like he's
received money from chinese firms that
he refused to report on
and now and his response was kelly
leffler is campaigning with a clansman
which is an overt lie
of course she's not campaigning with a
klansman she takes thousands of pictures
one of the pictures included a person
who happened to be a member of the clan
she immediately denounced that as soon
as she found out who was in the picture
with her and assaf says that he acts
like
she gets a grand wizard up there
introducing her at every rally
so he's just a damned liar this is this
is one of the more disgusting lies i've
heard
in in recent memory here is uh here's
john ossoff being disgusting
here's the bottom line kelly lefler has
been campaigning with a klansman
kelly lefler has been campaigning with a
klansman
and so she is stooping to these vicious
personal attacks
to distract from the fact that she's
been campaigning with a former member of
the ku klux klan
i mean we deserve better than that here
in georgia i mean no what we deserve
better then
is is people like jon ossoff who has
spent his benighted ridiculous trust
fund career
basically living off of his family's
large s and then trying to
facilitate his entry into politics
several times over and losing every time
he lost to karen handel then he lost a
purdue and now he's going to lose again
to purdue
we can hope today by the way this is the
same john ossoff
who uh apparently according to the
washington free beacon declined
a request from the washington post will
release further financial information
relating to his company
noting that the particulars of our
annual finances are confidential even
after a number of controversial payments
to assaf's foreign film company surfaced
in september including one
from a chinese-backed media giant the
refusal came months after assaf quietly
disclosed receiving at least five
thousand bucks from pccw
a hong kong-based media corporation
owned in part by the chinese communist
party
but his redirect is that kelly luffler
is kelly loeffler is a racist of course
assaf is the kind of delight by the way
who also says
that trump supporters should never show
their face in public again so remember
that georgian republicans if you're from
georgia and you're
not voting today remember the person who
could get elected to that tenancy
believes you should never be able to
show your face in public again
for the rest of your life here he is
john ossoff schmuck
we need to send a message this year
we need to send a message that if you
indulge this kind of politics
you're not just going to get beaten
you're going to get beaten so bad you
can never run or show your face again
in public because we have had enough
absolutely enough of what we are getting
from donald trump
and his fellow travelers right now okay
so um that sounds great
you want that guy in the senate if not
why don't you go vote go vote
today go vote if you've not voted yet go
vote today republicans
must hold the senate this isn't even
talking about this talking about who the
people are that you're talking about
elevating to the senate this isn't even
talking about the national
implications of this vote again kamala
harris running the united states senate
with joe biden in the presidency
and nancy pelosi in the house is a
disaster area beyond disaster areas get
ready for full-on nationalized
healthcare
really because the so-called public
option is as everyone
everyone knows just a gateway to full-on
nationalized healthcare that is the goal
and get ready for massive tax hikes and
tax increases get ready for
extraordinary violations of your
religious freedom
get ready for public schools to continue
to crack to cram down critical race
theory get ready for private schools to
meet crackdowns from the federal
government
get ready for churches to be attacked as
bastions of regressivism
get ready okay it comes down to those
two senate races today in georgia
the battle is on and if you're sitting
home there is no excuse for it on any
moral or political level none
we're going to get to more of this in
just one second and we'll get to
why it is that so many georgia georgia
citizens seem suspicious
of some of the procedures in the state
of georgia when it comes to voting
it is amazing to me that stacey abrams
who's been championed is you know this
this light and joy when it comes to
georgia voting after claiming for years
without any evidence that georgia was
engaged in voter suppression
i'm going to give you an example of why
people might be suspicious
of the fact that democrats wish
constantly to push forward with
procedures
that completely undercut voter
credibility and voter voter veracity
i'll get to that in one second first
let's talk about how you need to improve
your business you constantly need
to improve your business when you post a
job on ziprecruiter it gets sent out to
over 100 top job sites with one click
then zip recruiters matching technology
scans thousands of resumes and profiles
to send you
the most qualified people for your job
if you're really interested in a
candidate you can even invite them to
apply for your job with one click
zip recruiter sends them an email from
you you stand out from the competition
we use zip recruiter here at the daily
wire all the time we're a fast growing
company that means we are constantly
recruiting
new people to the company and we are
constantly replacing
bad old employees with better employees
they shall remain
nameless in any case ziprecruiter you
can try it for free at ziprecruiter.com
dailywire that zippercrew.com
d-a-i-l-y-w-i-r-e just head on over to
zip recruiter.com
daily wire zipper crews indeed the
smartest way to hire you want to make
sure
especially in this competitive economic
time that you're getting the best
employees if you are a potential
employee you want to make sure that you
are getting the best job listings
zip recruiter makes all of that happen
and again right now try zip recruiter
for free at zip recruiter.com
dailywire again that's ziprecruiter.com
dailywire okay we're gonna get back to
everything happening in georgia in just
one second then we'll get to the the
continued fallout from election 2020 and
the and the situation
in the senate and we're going to get
also to an extraordinary piece in the
new york times extraordinary
just doing chinese propaganda well we
are back to the days of walter durrancy
the new york times is just doing open
chinese propaganda at this point we'll
get to that in a second first
there's a reason millions of people
believe lies about conservatives that is
because you are constantly surrounded by
an
incredible measmatic cultural wave that
is it's just in the air it surrounds you
and it's it's a tsunami
right it's also it is both air and water
it's it's a tsunami that overwhelms you
of com of commentary and content and
entertainment
and culture that says that conservatives
are bad people
every narrative is driven to this extent
okay when people say the politics is
downstream from culture this is what
they mean
that when we have political discussions
about specific races or about specific
issues
all of that is downstream from
generalized feelings that people have
with regard to people across the
political aisle from them so when you
have an entire culture pushing the idea
that every conservative is john lithgow
from footloose that is a really really
problematic thing it is a really really
bad thing
now i always say facts don't care about
your feelings the problem is that
feelings very often don't care about
your facts culture shapes feelings
and this is why conservatives cannot
surrender the culture to the left we
have we've surrendered hollywood to the
left we've surrendered sports to the
left
we've surrendered so many areas of
american life to the left so daily wire
this year we are fighting back
we are fighting back we're doing
something that's risky for us as a
company but it is necessary and we need
your help
daily wire is jumping into the culture
we're doing that with our first motion
picture
run hide fight now this is not a
stereotypical conservative movie where
it's just you know some sort of altar
call for conservatism in fact
it's not particularly political because
the goal here is to drive people
to reconsider their stereotypes about
conservatives by providing them
entertaining content
that is not designed to preach at them
okay so this movie is designed
particularly for young people it is
intense
it is violent it is definitely rated r
it does have a powerful message to go
with it the movie follows a high school
besieged by a quartet of school shooters
one young girl 17 year old zoe hall
uses her wits and survival skills to
fight back
instead of some actors you will know
people like thomas jane it's really
really good you can watch the full
trailer on the daily wire youtube
channel
right now you're going to want to see it
it's great not only is it great it's
really important because we need to push
into the space conservatives spend their
lives whining about hollywood
you need to create a competitor you need
to help out competitors you need to make
sure that somebody is competing with the
netflix's and the amazons of the world
to ensure that people can actually see
entertainment that doesn't spit on them
every day of the week run hide fight is
the name of the film it will be
available to watch friday january 15th
my birthday over at dailywire.com we'll
be doing a special live stream premiere
the night before
thursday january 14th on the daily wire
youtube channel
let's kick off 2020 by fighting back in
the actual cultural wars creating our
own content
the cultural wars have to be fought
that's what we're doing here at daily
wire go check us out
dailywire.com subscribe you're listening
to the largest and fastest growing
conservative podcast in radio show in
the nation
okay so meanwhile in georgia obviously a
lot of people in georgia are very
concerned about voter procedures in for
in in the state one of the reasons that
people are very concerned is because
you have judges like stacy abrams sister
who literally attempted
to allow people who should not be
eligible to vote to vote
right their political reported december
28th a federal judge in georgia ordered
two counties to reverse a decision
removing more than four thousand voters
from the rules ahead of the january
fifth runoff elections that would decide
control of the united states senate the
judge is leslie abrams gardner
the sister of stacy abrams she concluded
that the counties appear to have
improperly relied on unverified change
of address data to invalidate
registration in the two counties so
basically what happened
is that there were some people they went
through the voter registration data they
found that there were literally
thousands of people who had changed
their addresses
the board of canvassing took a look at
this they found
that this was probably correct and they
wanted to invalidate the ability of
those people to vote
okay and then the plaintiffs said okay
we don't want this judge ruling on this
case because it turns out not only is
she stacey abram's sister but that
stacey abrams is involved in very very
similar litigation
and the lawyers in that litigation are
also the lawyers in this particular
litigation even though stacey abrams
isn't
directly involved in this litigation
right didn't matter stacey abram's
sister did not recuse herself she simply
ruled on it and she said okay well you
know what
we're going to we're just going to allow
people to essentially
register at false addresses i mean
that's that's essentially the outcome
of the case and she said you know what
there's no reason for me to recuse
so no big deal no big deal is it any
wonder that people are somewhat
suspicious here
somewhat suspicious but the media have
suggested that any republican who's
suspicious of any voting protocol
it's just because they're they're
gullible and they're full of it and
they're crazy
here's the thing i've suggested over and
over and over that allegations
especially outsized allegations required
outside of evidence i've been perfectly
consistent on this
across every single issue of which i am
aware whether you're alleging that
america is systemically racist
whether you're alleging that america is
systemically sexist whether you're
arguing that america's police are
targeting black americans whether you
are arguing
that that donald trump is a russian
asset i have always said whether you're
arguing about
allegations against brett kavanaugh i've
always said that evidence is the
final adjudicator as to whether a matter
is true or not this seems fairly obvious
right but you know who has not held the
standard like at all
democrats and members of the media who
have maintained that all of the
proposals that i just put forward as
lacking evidence are true
without providing any of the evidence
and so spare me the hysterics from
people like don lemon at cnn he says i
just
we can't we don't have to respect trump
supporters who believe this crap about
voter fraud
why you at cnn believe stacey abrams
crap about voter suppression
in a race she lost by 50 000 votes so
why why exactly
who are you to be sneering in other
words and here's don lemon on cnn doing
the sneering because again these are
your objective news media
and so stop saying that we must respect
trump supporters who believe
because
it is that you have been
feeding them the president and you
have been feeding them the bs and now
that they believe it all of a sudden you
again another self-fulfilling prophecy
and feedback loop now with that said i
do think that it is worthwhile noting
here
that the many of the allegations that
have been specifically made in georgia
have been in fact thoroughly debunked
doesn't mean every allegation has been
thoroughly debunked
it does mean that some of the more
egregious allegations dominion voting
for example or tens of thousands of dead
people voting
that sort of stuff that's it's not true
gabriel sterling
who is the elections official in georgia
did a very long press conference
yesterday and we
went through these allegations in detail
and if you care about facts you should
actually listen
to what gabriel sterling has to say i
understand that
it may debunk some ideas that people
have about
election verification in georgia i
understand that a lot of people want to
believe
what what president trump has said about
this sort of stuff but the bottom line
is that president trump
is not particularly detail-oriented i
don't think that he he really cares very
much about the specific allegations he
has the general tenor of the allegations
which is what he repeats
that's the way that trump does business
in some cases that's great in some cases
it really is not
here was gabriel sterling he was the
georgia voting system implementation
manager
talking about some of these specific
allegations there is no shredding of
balance going on
that's not real it's not happening no
one is changing parts or pieces
out of dominion voting machines that is
that's that's not a real i don't even
know what means it's not a real thing
um that's not happening the president
mentioned on the call yesterday or from
two days ago
that's again not real i don't even know
how exactly to explain that we have
claim
after claim after claim with zero proof
zero okay so here's the reality of the
situation
and you know who knows this everybody
including josh alley including ted cruz
including everybody on the republican
side of the aisle all the senate
election challenge stuff
that is slated for tomorrow it's gonna
go nowhere everybody knows this all of
this
okay there is no shot that donald trump
ends up as president on january 21st
based on these procedures
i i don't like saying uncomfortable
things but that is that is just a simple
fact of the matter
hey you know who knows that josh hawley
you know how we know he knows that
because last night bret bear asked him
specifically about it
and josh hawley had no answer to it and
bret bear said are you
are you saying that donald trump is
going to be president on january 21st or
has any shot at being president on
january 21st
and helly himself said the reason that
i'm challenging these votes is not
because i think that it's going to
change the outcome of the election
i'm doing it because i care about voter
fraud and voter integrity okay i also
care about voter fraud and voter
integrity
which is why we should redo the laws in
a lot of these states universal mail and
balloting is a disaster area it should
be redone
all of these laws need to be clarified
in states like pennsylvania
okay there needs to be immediate vote
counting as the counts come in
in the pre-vote in places like florida
so you can have right florida did this
and it was great
right georgia did not and so you end up
with these these days long counts
all that stuff should be changed we
should have voter id right all this
stuff is perfectly obvious
you don't challenge electoral college
votes based on that so
bret barrett asked hallie like is this
designed to change the outcome of the
election because it's not going to
and hallie basically acknowledged it's
not going to change the outcome of the
election
you've seen various senate republicans
say they won't support
they either won't object any states or
they won't support
any challenge any debate to any of these
electors so
their votes are their votes and and
people have to reach their own
conclusions
but i think it is absolutely imperative
when you look at something that happened
or like what happened in pennsylvania
for example where you had a state that
didn't even follow
its own constitution and its own laws
you've got
allegations of irregularities in that
state and many others
it is vital that we be heard on this
issue and we have a chance to debate it
and that's why i'm going to object
okay so even he is saying right there
yeah it's about debating voter fraud
it's it's not about it's it's not about
changing the outcome of the election
hallie knows that so
don't believe anybody in the media or
anywhere else who's telling you that
this is a litmus test
about fighting voter fraud or voter
irregularity it's not going to change a
damn thing
in terms of the outcome if you actually
want to change the voter fraud and voter
irregularity procedures you have to do
that within the states nor do you want
the federal government
especially a federal government run by
democrats being the final adjudicator of
what constitutes a free and fair
election
if you don't like democratic standards
for elections don't hand over democratic
elections to the federal government that
is like the worst solution that you
could have with regard
to some of this stuff okay meanwhile the
vaccine rollout continues to be
incredibly slow across america and
naturally
the media are blaming republicans which
makes it no sense since republicans are
the only ones who are actually
attempting to tranch out this vaccine
as fast as humanly possible meanwhile
you have andrew cuomo who has
simultaneously said that he's going to
find people a million dollars
for for not doing the prioritization
system properly in tranching out the
vaccines in other words if somebody
hands out a vaccine to the wrong person
he'll find you a million dollars also
if you waste a dose he'll find you a
million dollars okay this is the dumbest
thing i've ever heard
andre andrew cuomo is an awful awful
governor but who are the media focusing
on
they're focused laser-like on the
governor who's actually done the best
in terms of having a challenging
situation with millions and millions of
seniors living in his state
that would of course be ron desantis
florida's death per million rate is 19th
in america 19th okay but by media
coverage you would think that ron
desantis is the worst governor in
america he is not
so yesterday ron desantis rightly got
very pissed off
at a reporter because the reporter the
reporter decided she was just going to
basically ask him why he was a bad
person and he filled her in on why she
doesn't know anything about the vaccine
distribution process
we've seen websites crash and also
senior citizens waiting
overnight for the vaccine where was that
at we've seen it in duvall
broward orange and lee county why was
like in lee why did that happen
did you investigate why that's my
question to you governor you're the
governor of the state i'm not the
governor of the state
okay but you didn't investigate why that
happened lee county
why was there a big line did you did you
investigate why
could you tell us because we we
distributed vaccine
to hospitals and in the hospital said
first come first serve if you show up
we'll do it
so they didn't use a registration system
there wasn't anything that was done
and there's a lot of demand for it so
people are going to want to go ahead and
there was no
plan then from the state to make sure
that senior citizens didn't wait outside
overnight so the state is not dictating
the hospitals how we're not dictating to
carlos magoya
how he runs his operations here that
would be a total disaster
these guys are much more competent to be
able to deliver health care services
than a state government could ever be
okay the reality is it should not be
hard to trench out the vaccines
you have to get them to as many sites as
humanly possible and then just stick
everybody and do it and do it in order
of age if you show an id and it shows
that you are above the age of 70.
you go first if you're above the age of
65 you go second
if you're above the age of 60 you go
third right this is very not hard
it's really not hard not only that it
turns out we have an extraordinary
amount of vaccine that is sitting
and being wasted on the shelves because
these things have expiration dates
and they also exist in the freezer so
once you take them out of the freezers
particularly
the pfizer vaccine it goes bad after a
certain amount of time
which is why in in california apparently
there's a situation where somebody
removed
too much vaccine from the freezer and
there weren't enough people there so
they literally just went around started
sticking people people like that's great
why
why aren't we doing that everywhere good
question good question when desantis
says the reason people are showing up
for the vaccine
is because it is only being made
available in certain counties by certain
areas and people are showing up and they
will wait over
overnight in line to do it by the way my
parents would do that right my parents
are just under the 65 age limit
okay if the vaccine were made available
to them 100 they would camp out
overnight to get the vaccine so they
could see
their other grandchildren right 100 they
would do that
and there are ways to get the vaccine
out there faster that we are not taking
advantage of one
stop holding back the second doses of
vaccine you idiots
hey there is the first dose of vaccine
it provides a significant amount of
immunity
there's the second dose you don't hold
that in a freezer for a month you trench
out all the vaccines right now second
there's open talk now about the fact
that one half a dose of the vaccine
is exactly the same and its immune
response is what dr slowly over
operational warp speed says
as an entire dose of the vaccine so you
cut it all those doses in half
you have now quadrupled the amount of
vaccine in circulation
and you do this by age it is not hard it
is unbelievable that we have not
trenched out more vaccine at this point
it's simply incredible that we have not
done that at this point so
guys get on your horses if you would
like the vaccine to be trenched out so
we can all get back to something
resembling normal life
then stop with all the fda cdc garbage
and get the vaccine out the door as fast
as possible to the oldest people
possible and then move on down the chain
alrighty we'll be back here later today
with an additional hour of content
otherwise we will see you here later i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
production manager pavel wydowsky our
associate producers are rebecca doyle
and savannah dominguez
the show is edited by adam's high events
audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica crams
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright 2020.
you know the matt wall show it's not
just another show about about politics i
think there are enough of those
already out there we talk about culture
because culture drives
politics and it drives everything else
so my main focuses are
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about i
hope you'll give it a listen